[Music]
hey everyone my name is Jake Decker and
now that the ìiî dust is settled we're
going to take some time to show you some
smaller games you might have missed
every day at 8 a.m. for the rest of the
week we will be spotlighting a new indie
game we will be looking at couch co-op
games like River bond all the way to
road redemption a spiritual successor to
Road Rash if you have any questions feel
free to hit me up on twitter at jacob
deck and i hope you all enjoy it is e 3
2017 and I am here with David from
bishop games he brought us light fall to
take a look at before we get started
what what is like fall what's the
premise so light fall is a platformer in
which you have your own platform
actually so it gives a player a lot more
control on how we want to go about with
inside the level cool um well let's
let's get in take a look at this game
alright I really like the art style yeah
thank you it's a so actually we decided
to go with a silhouette style because
then in this world which is numbre
there's never they like so it's always
in permanent darkness it's uh it seems
pretty fast too it's pretty fast
platform what was that but she's good
yeah so we have a story going on so
right now there's a metal ore that just
uh just over yeah it reminds me it kind
of seems like Super Meat Boy in a sense
of how like quick it is and how you're
clinging on different ledges yeah yeah
so right now we are just making sure
that the player knows how to run how to
jump and do the wall jumps as well but
just around the corner I'm about to
unlock the main mechanic of the game
which is the shadow core that is just
right here so this block that you are
unliking right now it allows you that
that's a platform I talked about a bit
earlier so we'll see how it works
whoa all right so now we are another
dimension but that's a little part of
the story so right now when I jump if
I'm midair I can press the jump button
again and now it's found spinning okay
and if I go horizontally it will follow
me
so it's really safe actually so you can
save yourself from a certain death okay
but the downside is that I have only
four charges so right now then you have
to touch ground yeah exactly
looks like you you're good about so then
can you upgrade your platform or is it
always for charges and that's it it's
always for charges so it's really about
the player to get better with it yeah as
a game I kind of like that it's more
about skill rather yeah exactly so at
first it challenges you will find them
hard but if you try the first few levels
again it later you will feel find it
really easy actually
you can also spun it on the sides
because to do wall jumps because right
here I have like limited height but fast
planet on the sides I can go much higher
so so there are multiple dimensions that
you'll be going to or is it just kind of
like this one and then that other one
yes so I even talked about that yeah of
course um so when you go inside this
dimensions ah it's because you are going
into the gods realm which is a bit it's
limited basically so that everybody can
go there and you can go there but for
most of the game you will spend it
inside nombre sorry here we are
the
uh is this is this mostly platforming or
their enemies that you'll run into right
so the first few levels we are just
having a small challenges so on purpose
the first level has no enemies okay just
so that the player can get a grasp on
the black mechanic right but under the
other levels we have enemies throughout
the entire game and then do you is there
way to deal damage to them or is it more
just try to avoid them yeah you can deal
damage to them which I will be showing
off as soon as we we get an enemy cool
as you can see right now we also have
the cutscenes which happen in between
each level of the game so the game is
actually fairly intensive in story wise
it's not the game is about the story
which is about less friendship and
sacrifice so without getting too much
into the details we on purpose try to
get to get you two different feelings so
sine is happiness even you get mad at
some point as well okay how long is the
how long do you anticipate the game to
be for the average player we are talking
about four hours of gameplay um which is
on purpose short actually because as
gamers we we don't have that much time
anymore to be honest and it's been a
long time since I finished any game yeah
um it I mean maybe it's just because
it's going so fast but it almost looks
like it's good for speedrunning - yeah
it is we actually have a speedrun mode
that is embedded inside a game and in
that mode you will have a leaderboard
and you'll be able to challenge the
ghost of the best player of the world
for example as with your friends yeah so
here I'm unlocking a new feature of the
block which allows me to move it around
and here I can place it here and I block
that laser so now I can go through
but if you feel like it actually since
you have this blog that allows you to go
pretty much anywhere you can go and
explore a bit more and if I go here I
will find a hidden dungeon so these are
meant to be challenging so yeah yeah so
the dungeons they hide are collectibles
and just just collecting the collectible
isn't good enough right so now it
follows me and if I really want to
collect it I have to bring it to the
nearest checkpoint with me okay like so
and so if you die on your way you just
you lose a collector you have to go back
exactly exactly
is there is there a benefit to
collecting the nor is it just mostly to
collect them just to add a little extra
challenge yeah so those are collectibles
when you come when you get there damn it
gives you a page from the front puddle
wood so that the wood is the first
Explorer okay and he wrote a journal so
it's a page of that journal nice that is
just a tool or exactly so its lore and
it allows you to learn more about the
world of number I and how it was
centuries ago when when you just
discovered it is it is it tough to make
a platforming game where you can spawn a
platform wherever you want
yeah well it's kind of a it's kind of
bold actually so sometimes it's more
challenging because we don't want the
player to be overly powerful right it
has to be a challenge but at the same
time it gives us more freedom on what we
want to do are in those platformers
because there's this really strict
length and height that people can reach
the metrics are really important and
over time players realize that the
challenges they are all at the same
distance from each other right yeah
you recognize that patterns really
quickly so like here if you want to you
can place the block here right but if
you as you get more experience to figure
that you can do it like that whoa whoa
that was cool
so as the black fall follows your is
until you write until you land on
you can do it like that okay much faster
and we do it on purpose actually so that
the speedrunners can find them though I
find those small tricks and actually I
did the one I'm about to show off it I
didn't do it on purpose um somebody
found it so I can expand a block like
that as well that's right which is that
so it's for the side jumps but if I do
if I spun it and just fall down it
allows me yet but protects me and we
actually happen to use it a bit more
into the game so at some point you just
have to use it like that so I mean it
seems pretty apparent now but like
because you're able to spawn your own
platform it there's a little bit more
experimentation yeah to it I feel like
rather than like what you're saying it's
not just here's the critical path to get
through instead there's yeah so of
course we have this a bit more obvious
bad that the every player can use but on
purpose we create up at alternative
paths and every single level that are
faster but more challenging so if you
are a speedrunner you want to find those
yeah so here I it's another feature of
the block so if you press the X button
on the xbox controller you get to attack
with the block like that okay so that's
how you break walls and you will be
attacking enemies like that as well so
here I have another kind of collectible
so those are hidden frozen characters
that I get to free like that so I have
to find them alright so this one was a
bit obvious to find but most will be
hidden inside the levels what is that I
guess that thing to that in the
background what is the elephant looking
yeah so this guide the second level is
all about learning about the gods that
exists into this realm so this guy is
our log and is the the god of time he is
known to be silly and he doesn't really
has all of his mind anymore but
is one of the characters and that will
be an ally throughout the game then how
about bad guy works people like I look
scary yeah so this guy is a Shem so he
is the wrath of the elements so he's
more of the fighter of the gods the
other ones they have different powers so
it's not all about fighting right that's
not yeah just how you get you become a
garden in that universe but this guy is
he is the dangerous one
okay um obviously I'm gonna go into
spoilers but is there boss fights in
this game yes there is so I wonder who
we might be fighting down the line
I will see so actually in the next level
we will get a small piece of the boss
fight that's when the demolicious ends
so right before the first boss fight
so this one is Luke's Anna it's one of
the main guards
so she's the goddess of light and since
the the people moved in to noon bruh
which is in permanent darkness she
doesn't get much attention anymore
because there's no sunlight right so the
goddess of light is a bit left left out
right then next question the thatäôs
shows that is he just kind of I think
it's an owl is he just like showing that
it like figure to checkpoint or is there
more okay story so actually the narrator
that you can hear in the game
it's the owl that okay um so in the
first level you just like looks from far
away doesn't want to get involved
because is quite grumpy to be honest and
he's old is done his share and it
doesn't want to get involved with a
troublesome guy just just like the
character of the game but eventually
gets gets involved in he's not that
happy about it to be honest it does it
because it's the good thing to do
because there's those shiny being
crystals that that's found everywhere
and those were not there before so it's
the new threat inside nombre
okay
oh this is completely different yeah so
uh now we reached a third level of the
first chapter and it happens on the
highest montane of the land so in there
the sunlight can be true yeah just a
little bit and actually each it's
different alright so I need to
concentrate for this one so for every
chapter of the game we are changing the
the color palette of the game so as
progress I it feels different so every
every cover every chapter is is
different cool
I like the minimalistic colorful
silhouette design yeah thank you thank
you very much
so here as you can check and place the
block and take a look at will so I
control the boat and the tractor right
now so will there be different level
different levels have different sort of
yes exactly so that's that's how we make
sure that that the game just keeps
progressing and that it doesn't feel
like the same thing going on again and
again as you don't unlock many things
right
yeah that's how we make the game feel
refreshing every time you play it and I
take it you don't want to get hit by
those no no those are nasty can you cue
jewel damage to them or is it are they
just more of an obstacle yeah so every
enemy you can actually interact with
them in different ways so you can either
hit them and they are gone or you can
like days them so here we have this
laser right so you know you can't go
there because it will hurt you so what
you have to do actually is you have to
go out there and you bring the boat on
the other side like that okay and now
you you get you get across
through here and now I can keep going so
I have a choice here I can go with the
boat as expected but if I feel like if I
can just skip and try to go without the
boat geez and you cannot actually do the
entire level without the boat so really
yeah and so here we we hide one of those
so how difficult is because I could
imagine this getting pretty difficult
near the end yeah yeah it certainly does
but at the same time in this game it
just feels so good to go fast you just
want to go fast all the time and that's
when you will die most of the time yeah
it seems like if you if you take it slow
it won't be as difficult but it's it the
rule the rewarding part is yeah exactly
gonna move quickly through these levels
yeah so it really fits different players
play style so if you feel like going
really fast you can and if we feel
really good but if you are I think a
tough tough part of the level that
you're not able to get through you can
just take your time
and you will make it yeah it's just
about patience sometimes
that's really cool so someone could have
taken about all through that if they
wanted to yeah you can just skip it all
of it but it's much more challenging but
that's what speedrunners I will be doing
they will be skipping the boat and just
go through alright this looks ominous
yeah so that's the entrance to the bus
at the first chapter so do we see the
boss or is it end right away we see it
but we don't get to fight it okay all
right so he's right there behind in
Chains that's really cool yeah thank you
thank you for stopping by that was light
fall is there anything else you'd like
to add so if you're interested into
light fall you can go into too light
fall game comm where you can find more
information about the game thank you for
watching if you want to see more videos
like this make sure to subscribe until
next time thank you alright thank you
you